[Music]
hey hey hey can't fall asleep in here
it's hot it's like really hot this fan
was working yesterday dose water ah okay
got the fan going that's a little bit of
loose I'm started the car to be easy but
got a lot to do today so we'll get 200
bright and early
why were you sleeping in there by the
way
Krim warm air feels
ah
that's not good problem that fan ain't
gonna cut it it's roasting hot in here
cheek is not gonna survive if we have to
be in the stock car this whole time and
the air conditioning doesn't work wise
man once said on a wet surface of work
so we've got a problem
ha loser so hot beans not writing to the
board it's not because I sprayed it with
water like an idiot that's can't be the
reason why it's um it's hot as you can
plainly see we got this van to be mobile
if you remember on the board that I just
wiped off why didn't that just keep that
ah doesn't matter don't worry about it
that's my problem not your problem and
we got this van to be mobile but we
can't go anywhere cuz frankly I'm
worried about Chico more than worried
about me Chico where are you spell it
out fill up h.o.t hot so how do we solve
this problem
hold my side alright so I got this thing
it's called the hyper cool with a ke WL
I hate that ok but here's how it works
so evaporative cooling products are
designed for people working or playing
in the summer heat workers play for us
that's good
Proctor easy to use submerge in water
for 1 to 2 minutes into ok alright well
you're so
one to two minutes be patient okay
all right so we've got a temporary
solution but it's not gonna do us any
good water and for chica hey how about
drape this around your jackets go keep
you guys up cool okay but just for a
little bit so what we got to do is we've
got to quickly find something for chica
that's gonna be more than just this
towel because this is gonna keep her
cool for long so you gonna need water
she's gonna need a better bed we're
gonna need some kind of solution to fix
the AC where's my whiteboard there
excuse me it's hot
but I bet you didn't know that I was
actually making this into an anagram
h.o.t which stands for heat over thought
which means the heat is just in your
mind high oxygen temperature heat
actually stands for high oxygen
temperature it's really only the oxygen
that has any heat in it so if we didn't
breathe that oxygen we would never
actually get hot but unfortunately we
live in a universe where hot heavy
oxidized Teflon you and I'm saying step
step step number eight
how do coal because this is white no I
just realized oh how no no wow Oh
temperature we need a way to measure the
temperature you buckled up back there ah
yeah I have a seatbelt so we're gonna
use this are you gonna call I know who
has oh hi hi how's it going I'm pretty
good it's really hot yeah do you
remember that like laser gun thing oh
cool okay that's weird
oh yeah okay cool
I've never horned hot okay the AC
doesn't work in this fan yeah so it's
really hot but yes I would like that
very much thank you
98 degrees on your leg really okay god
it's good right yeah kind of right in my
eye please don't oh god I don't know die
alright so um can you give me my
whiteboard we've solved for H which is
how do cold so we need to solve for oh
that's weird
yeah it is weird she's not doing so hot
nailed it nice ban right yeah did you
come up with a name for it no God let me
over this freaking emergencies
everywhere let me overcome pain that'd
be over
oh it's so hot my knees bring me pants
wet what kind of reading we get in on
those neat bits okay so we're at the pet
store because chica always comes first
in everything right chica you dare right
girl you always come first
really special and you're probably very
hot but this is a store that you can go
in radio let's go do it
[Music]
all right so what we got going on here
is we got chica all settled we got her
water we got her bed we got our bull
we've still got a few other problems we
need to solve the air-conditioner
problem
I've never fixed an air-conditioner but
how are good it'd be right right right
take a cup ice water - good girl
oh yeah good girl filled water even that
water is getting a toasty 84 degrees we
can who cannot here's a story we're at
ko centric circle store I looked up a
tutorial on the internet about how to
replace AC refrigerant in this van to
make it cool in here I'm going to trust
you with the vehicle don't take it for a
joyride now alright
[Music]
then in half their car selection was
reduced by their boot aureum they talk
[ __ ] about the food park I'm talking to
me about the boot pouring why don't we
go to that's not gonna cover it all yeah
so we've got the H we've got the oh now
we need the T which stands for
technology
hey funny thing this fish smells really
bad it is pristine
if there's one thing that can quench
your thirst on a hot summer day
actually it's fall but let's ignore that
fact it's none other than oh never mind
you go ice skating same story
we'll be right back chickie you'll be
good
[Music]
now what we need to got AC Pro it says
number one rated coldest air and I don't
know about you but I trust this guy in
the bottle so I'm gonna trust him with
my life and I'm gonna put this in this
car you get the temperature gauge you
never know when it's gonna fluctuate and
at any moment it just below I got it it
is supposed to be on line
that looks safe am I gonna be able to
break these hi I got it oh no I can't
risk that no it's totally fun maybe I
should read this I'm ready you're ready
unscrew and remove it says for the
record I'm not a car guy I've never been
a car guy I went to engineering school
that doesn't mean I know cars don't
assume anything about me my knowledge is
incredibly limited
righty-ho maybe I should lift there's
more instructions here
let's give that a gander okay all right
cool okay all right got it
rates off this bad boy all right
that was a weird reading but
now what it's supposed to be it seems
too quick and be an outside temperature
Oh what temperature is it right now it's
point straight up Chris and I should
read all the insertion before eggs I
start doing this and know if the
compressor is cycled on and the pressure
is in the red do not attempt to recharge
seek professional help
Oh was I supposed to shake this
good enough I always love explosions I'm
just gonna let it go this happens the
guy said it could take up to eight
minutes so maybe I'm just being a little
[ __ ] here shake can well probably
important
it was scary at first now I realize this
is gonna take a while
yeah I get it so the like that's that's
like and then which is like the that is
handy-dandy yeah hey it's getting there
hopefully anyway
[Music]
I just read something on the side that
said always wear protective goggles and
gloves
weird
oh that was the longest go yet
[Music]
get the temperature reader read the
temperature on those beds
yeah I've never done look at chica I
can't believe it that was so scary
it may be some more soon because it
emptied this can just get in the green
but that was not bad I could do that
again we could do that again
oh yeah old ladies fall it's a now the
only thing left to do is we got it thing
is I think I think you had something in
mind good one so it's been a fun day and
thank you so much Jamie for helping out
you got the heat problem solved but I
think that also got solved when the Sun
went down but nonetheless there was one
person out there King Stevens game said
your vans the inside looks like you're
sitting inside a barrel and I really
want to take this thing to Cracker
Barrel so I think an honor that we got
to call it barrel and the barrel
climbing the barrel we're gonna take the
barrel down the Falls take the barrel
down the Falls you don't think this bad
boy would float honestly you you deserve
the right to christen this lovely barrel
all right I guess you left your mark
either way that's my name
[Music]
all right so thank you so much for
joining me this is a lot of fun thank
you Amy
thank you chica say you're welcome
I don't think she can but uh most
importantly thank you and as always I'll
see you in the next video bye
[Music]